[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález este
es el espacio de france 24 en el que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
del cob y 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación les presento el sumario de
temas que tenemos para el programa de
hoy
uno de los mandatarios que más minimizó
el peligro y el avance del cobi 19 ha
sido diagnosticado con este coronavirus
donald trump el presidente de eeuu y su
esposa melania están aislados y
recibiendo también tratamiento para
combatir esta enfermedad tenemos los
detalles
y la reapertura económica avanza en
américa latina pero no de manera
uniforme varias regiones del sur de
chile y del norte de brasil han tenido
que retomar el confinamiento de algunas
restricciones porque siguen aumentando
los casos mientras que en perú hay una
drástica caída en el número de contagios
vamos a ver que lo que está sucediendo
en ese país andino y semanas atrás
reportábamos el buen manejo de varios
países en el caribe a la hora de hacer
frente a la situación de la pandemia del
joven 19 ahora todo ha cambiado ahora la
situación es preocupante en algunos de
estos territorios el rápido avance del
virus y los pequeños sistemas de salud
están empezando a preocupar en
archipiélagos como bahamas y trinidad y
tobago veremos las cifras y conoceremos
cómo es la situación pues vamos a
comenzar entonces en el extremo norte de
nuestro continente vamos a dar una
mirada rápida cómo está la situación
allí el primer ministro de canadá justin
junto indicó varios días atrás que la
segunda ola de contagio ya estaba
teniendo lugar en ese país
y canadá ya registra más de 164.000
casos confirmados el premier canadiense
indicó que el 12 de octubre que es el
día de acción de gracias' canadiense
podría no ser celebrado como lo indica
la tradición de otra parte méxico ya
superó los 700 mil casos este país
también cumplió siete meses de haber
diagnosticado el primer caso de kobe 19
y ahora avanza en su reapertura con
algunas zonas que todavía se mantienen
en máxima alerta por el alto número de
casos en eeuu donde hay más de 7.3
millones de casos confirmados los
estados de california texas florida
illinois wisconsin y carolina del norte
son los más afectados ya lo decíamos en
el avance del sumario el presidente de
este país es donald trump el más
incrédulo en torno a la pandemia y su
esposa melanie a trump fueron
diagnosticados con kobe 19
vamos entonces a la ciudad de washington
allí se encuentra diana castañeda la
corresponsal de france 24 en la capital
estadounidense
hola diana y cuál es el último reporte
sobre la salud del presidente donald
trump y de su esposa melania
hola santiago pues el presidente se
encuentra en el hospital walter reed en
donde será atendido por los médicos por
los síntomas que ha registrado por colom
habidos y de manera preventiva se
encuentra en la suite presidencial y los
síntomas que ha registrado hasta el
momento son fatiga y también molestia en
la garganta al igual que su esposa sin
embargo antes de ir al hospital que
quiero un vídeo asegurando que se
encontraba optimista y que agradecía el
apoyo de toda la gente que ha expresado
su solidaridad también se sabe que está
siendo sometido a un tratamiento
experimental que no ha sido hasta el
momento certificado por la fd a también
se le está suministrando según lo dijo
la casa blanca y su médico personal
vitamina de zinc y aspirina el
presidente ha iniciado esta cuarentena
pero no se sabe si estará durante dos
semanas por completo en el hospital o si
después se ha trasladado a otro lugar
jana que se sabe de joe biden y de su
esposa que esta semana estuvieron en un
debate con el presidente de donald trump
un debate que tuvo todos los
cuidados de bioseguridad pero que
también a lo largo de las semanas
estuvieron en encuentros con diferentes
en diferentes partes del país con sus
seguidores que se sabe de la de la salud
del candidato demócrata
así es inmediatamente se conoció la
noticia de que el presidente había dado
positivo y la primera dama por
coronavirus el presidente decidió que
muchos miembros de sus familias se
sometieron a esta prueba pero también el
candidato su contrincante demócrata a la
presidencia yo bailé se realizó la
prueba el día de hoy que dio negativo al
igual que su esposa después de que esta
semana estuviera participando en un
debate junto al presidente también el
vicepresidente pins se realizó la prueba
salió negativo al igual que su esposa y
en el caso de la familia del presidente
de su hijo menor dio negativo y su hija
ivanka hecho am al igual que su esposo
también vieron en negativo se sabe que
el presidente pudo haber sido contagiado
por corona vinos por su asistente
heights o también por la encargada del
comité nacional republicano que también
dio positivo y estuvieron en contacto
con el mandatario también el presidente
estuvo justo ayer en un evento donde
estuvo en contacto con decenas de
personas en un evento para recaudar
fondos y las autoridades
hershey en donde se encontraba el
presidente están tratando de contactar a
las personas que estuvieron en este
lugar para que se hagan la prueba ya no
estamos en las semanas más importantes
de la campaña presidencial para las
elecciones del 3 de noviembre cómo
afecta esta noticia el debate
vicepresidencial que está previsto para
el 7 de octubre en el estado de utah
bueno pues hasta el momento la campaña
del presidente no ha dicho nada sobre si
será cancelado o no este debate que se
espera que se realice en solicitud y en
la universidad de utah con el
vicepresidente pensé y con la fórmula a
la vicepresidencia por el partido
demócrata kamala harris pero lo que se
sabe es que el presidente ha cancelado
pues todos los rallyes todos estos
grandes eventos en donde tenía contacto
con miles de personas también ha
cancelado los eventos para recaudar
fondos que tenían contacto con personas
la campaña ha dicho que todavía no sabe
si para el próximo debate que tenía el
presidente don al tronco le aire se hará
de manera virtual pero que están
estudiando cambios en el formato que
dependerán de cómo avance el estado de
salud del presidente en su recuperación
después de este diagnóstico diana donald
trump tendrá que estar por unas semanas
fuera de sus actividades como ya usted
lo decía pero es que también queda de
lado la actividad como presidente de
estados
como candidato de los republicanos cómo
afecta entonces esto el proceso
electoral ya usted nos da unas luces de
cómo afecta un poco y las modificaciones
que tendrán que hacer en la campaña de
los republicanos pero el mandatario es
el presidente también entonces el donald
tropieza el presidente entonces pues
afecta también la presidencia
así es es muy cierto quedan 32 días para
las elecciones y básicamente la
constitución en su enmienda número 25
establece que cuando un presidente no
puede cumplir sus funciones se debe
hacer un juramento al vicepresidente
quien asume las funciones del presidente
en el caso de que el presidente
donaldson tuviera que llegar digamos a
este escenario sería mike pence quien
tendría que llevar a cabo las funciones
pero si el presidente pues después
registra una recuperación completa esta
sería una transición simplemente
momentánea en el caso de que se llegara
a presentar este escenario sin embargo
hoy precisamente la casa blanca aseguró
que el vicepresidente pensó no había
juramentado es decir que el presidente
de donaldson continúa realizando sus
funciones y se sabe que también en esta
suite presidencial en el hospital ruiz
tiene una oficina lo que no se sabe es
por cuánto tiempo continuará ejerciendo
las funciones esto dependerá de su
estado de salud y vamos a seguir muy
atentos a lo que ocurre allí en la
ciudad de washington diana muchas
gracias por este reporte en torno a la
salud del presidente y también candidato
a la presidencia de eeuu donald trump
vamos a seguir en ese país
norteamericano porque más de 25 mil
restaurantes de la ciudad de nueva york
comenzaron poco a poco a abrir las
puertas nuevamente a recibir también
clientes después de seis meses de cierre
pero después de haber sido uno de los
focos de la pandemia del hobby 19 están
verdaderamente los neoyorquinos listos
para regresar a los restaurantes veamos
a continuación
[Música]
bajo estrictas medidas los restaurantes
abren su interior en nueva york' el
personal debe cambiar su mascarilla cada
20 minutos y lavarse las manos cada 15
además se toma la temperatura de cada
persona que ingresa
pero que los restaurantes regresen no
significa que los clientes lo harán
muchas personas aún tienen miedo de
salir o su economía no se los permite
y para mí es un poco conflictivo estoy
feliz de estar afuera ahora y me
gustaría que los restaurantes
invirtieran más en calentadores y
permitir cenar al aire libre el tiempo
que sea necesario
[Música]
para quienes están cómodos comiendo
adentro que lo hagan pero para mí la
prioridad es tener a mis hijos en la
escuela para mí reabrir la escuela es
más importante que comer en el interior
de un restaurante
si nueva york fuera un país sería el
séptimo con más muertes por kobe 19 en
el mundo con 33 mil 153 fallecimientos
en marzo los hospitales y morgues de la
gran manzana colapsaron los restaurantes
ya habían abierto sus terrazas en junio
mientras que los museos que comenzaron a
recibir visitantes en agosto también
abrieron con un aforo del 25 por ciento
a uno es una reapertura es como abrir un
restaurante nuevo tuvimos que re
contratar personas y entrenar las y
finalmente nos permitieron abrir el
interior gobernar latas open indoor
tenemos 25 por ciento de capacidad así
que con muy pocas sillas pero es mejor
que nada
las autoridades de nueva york también
permitieron la reapertura gradual de las
escuelas sin embargo el aumento de casos
en varios sectores aún es motivo de
preocupación
y nos vamos ahora a esta américa del sur
allí avanza la primavera austral pero
también está avanzando la reapertura en
algunos de los países y por supuesto la
constante lucha contra el cóver 19
veamos algunas de las cifras comenzamos
en guyana este país suramericano aquí lo
ven en verde está registrando cerca de
2.900 casos su población es de medio
millón de habitantes y tiene un sistema
de salud muy pequeño y con pocos
recursos la alerta está ante los pocos
respiradores artificiales que además
están todos concentrados en georgetown
que es la capital no muy lejos de allí
en surinam también en la parte del norte
de suramérica es este país en un color
un poco más anaranjado allí se
contabilizan 4800 casos al igual que
guyana la concentración de la atención
hospitalaria de alto nivel está en
paramaribo que es la capital y se estima
que los números de casos en las zonas
rurales que la mayoría de ellas son
selváticas son mayores de las que cuenta
el gobierno
el departamento de ultramar francés de
la guyana francesa tiene más de 9.900
casos registrados hasta ahora
ser un ex clave de la unión europea
mantiene sus fronteras cerradas para los
habitantes de otros países de suramérica
y un poco más lejos de allí un poco más
al sur argentina es un país con una de
las cuarentenas más largas del mundo
cierra esta semana con más de 765 mil
casos registrados
vamos a seguir en sudamérica porque el
estado y la ciudad de río de janeiro en
brasil son precisamente los que están
registrando la mayor cantidad de muertes
y ya llevan cerca de 4 meses con un
precipitado proceso de des escalamientos
de las medidas instauradas y también de
una apertura económica y social valeria
sakon en nuestra corresponsable en río
de janeiro nos cuenta cómo está la
situación allí
desde el 1 de octubre reabren en río de
janeiro los teatros y los cines eso sí
con algunas limitaciones aforo limitado
al 50% mascarilla obligatoria siempre el
hidrogel para desinfectar las manos y
dentro de la sala un metro y medio de
distancia entre las personas para
reducir el riesgo de contagio también
pueden abrir las salas de conciertos es
decir los espectáculos están permitidos
pero no las ruedas de samba que son los
tradicionales conciertos que suelen
abarrotar las calles de toda la ciudad
con la alegría típica de esta música
tampoco pueden reabrir de momento las
escuelas de samba y esto es un gran
golpe para ese sector que facturan
muchos millones de dólares cada año de
hecho la semana pasada supimos que el
carnaval de febrero ha sido de momento
suspendido sin conocer una fecha porque
se espera a que haya una vacuna
curiosamente las playas están cerradas a
pesar de que hemos visto desde hace
semanas la imagen de muchas personas
tomando el sol y tomando baño en teoría
se puede solamente acceder a la playa
para hacer deporte o para estar dentro
del agua pero no hay controles y los
cariocas no aguantan este calor no
aguantan 7 meses de reclusión y están
acudiendo numerosos a las playas todos
los fines de semana en un momento en que
la ciudad se acerca a los 19 mil muertos
y tenemos una curva muy ascendiente
desde hace 17 días el 1 de octubre fue
el primer día en que hubo una pequeña
estabilización pero los especialistas
están poniendo el grito en el cielo los
hospitales comienzan a estar llenos en
algunos casos hasta el 90% de las camas
hospitalarias están llenos y los
epidemiológicas dicen que sería lo ideal
dar una marcha atrás en esta reapertura
pero estamos en un periodo electoral y
el alcalde de río de janeiro en marcelo
crivella está aspirando a la reelección
y no quiere tomar ninguna iniciativa que
sea impopular en el otro extremo del
país en manaos tenemos una situación
bien diferente porque es verdad que
están aumentando los casos un 30
de repuntes 4000 muertos desde el
principio de la pandemia pero el alcalde
está pensando en imponer un lock down
estricto de dos semanas precisamente
para evitar aquellas escenas que vimos
al principio de la pandemia con un
colapso de los hospitales y
lamentablemente falsas comunes en los
cementerios ya lo estaba mencionando
valeria desde el río de janeiro la
ciudad de manaos que es la ciudad más
importante en el amazonas brasileño
vuelve a ser noticia por los rebrotes y
por el inminente cierre de la actividad
comercial y la vida social por la
cantidad de casos que están teniendo
lugar allí que fue lo que sucedió se los
explicamos en el siguiente reportaje
la des escalada y va progresando incluso
se ha afirmado que podría ser uno de los
primeros lugares del planeta en alcanzar
la inmunidad de rebaño pero el
resurgimiento de los casos de kobe 19 en
manaos la ciudad más grande de la
amazonas brasileño ha puesto en alerta a
las autoridades
un análisis internacional liderado por
investigadores de la universidad de sao
paulo indica que entre el 44 y el 66% de
la población contrajo el virus entre
mediados de mayo y agosto la cantidad de
pacientes colapso del sistema
hospitalario y los cementerios no daban
abasto sin embargo con el pasar de las
semanas las muertes disminuyeron de 60
decesos diarios en abril pasaron a sólo
dos o tres al final de agosto y la
situación se fue normalizando de a pocos
no obstante los números han vuelto a
aumentar es por ello que desde el
viernes las autoridades locales
decidieron cerrar playas y bares
prohibir reuniones y restringir las
horas de funcionamiento de restaurantes
y tiendas durante 30 días
el gobierno debe tomarse esto en serio y
hablar con la verdad decir lo que está
pasando y lo que no por dos razones y
que a quien no tiene problema si dicen
que no hay problema no recibiremos ayuda
si dice que no hay problema eso
impulsará a las personas a ignorar
nuestros decretos
las autoridades han indicado que los
contagios se han incrementado entre
personas jóvenes que asisten a lugares
públicos y desarrollan síntomas leves
sin embargo ellos contagian a familiares
mayores que a menudo terminan bajo
tratamiento hospitalario
y algunas regiones de chile ya sienten
el buen clima de la primavera austral
esto ha acompañado a los habitantes
sobre todo los que residen en la región
metropolitana en donde ya hay
prácticamente una apertura total caso
contrario sucede en el sur del país así
es como está la situación en este país
para unos pocos fue un día más en la
capital chilena para otros primer día de
libertad tras varios meses de
restricciones
estábamos colapsando el elevado número
de contagios de coronavirus que registró
la capital chilena obligó a las
autoridades a implementar una de las más
largas y restrictivas cuarentenas la
movilidad fue limitada al mínimo en
lugares emblemáticos de la ciudad fueron
cerrados sabemos que es una etapa
positiva porque vamos avanzando en este
paso a paso pero también decirles que
estamos en pandemia
estamos en pandemia y si no respetamos
las medidas y se aumentan los casos
vamos a tener que retroceder cosa que
las personas no quieren hacer porque el
impacto negativo que tiene estar en
cuarentena es muy grande no solamente
para ellos sino que para toda la familia
para muchos de quienes estuvieron bajo
las restricciones la retoma de
actividades era ya un imperativo la
gente necesita trabajar
pero creo que no están dadas las
condiciones todavía porque si tú me
preguntas si en el puente a estuvimos
cuarentenas nunca la hubo el zoológico
de la ciudad y sitios para tomar un café
estuvieron entre los más visitados
después de siete meses
wilson vuelve a abrir sus puertas en el
cne una etapa co y te estamos con un
recorrido que es diferente con reservas
con una serie cosa que no son parte de
nuestra cultura para visitar lugares
como el nuestro chile es la sexta nación
en américa latina' más afectada por
casos de coronavirus con casi 460 mil
contagios y más tics 12.000 muertes y en
menos de un mes el país celebrará un
plebiscito nacional por una nueva
constitución nos vamos hasta santiago la
capital de chile allí se encuentra
patricia luna nuestra corresponsal que
nos va a dar más detalles de la
situación allí hola patricia - por favor
e impresiones de primera mano porque
usted está allí en la ciudad de santiago
en el área metropolitana de cómo avanza
esa apertura prácticamente total de la
capital chilena
hola santiago pues a las cinco de esta
mañana a las dos comunas de la región
metropolitana que siguen confinada rehn
que hay pajines saldrán finalmente de su
confinamiento avanzarán a la fase dos de
las cinco del gobierno y con esto por
primera vez en seis meses la región
metropolitana que concentra a 8 de los
18 millones de chilenos estará
totalmente desconfiada hoy salimos a la
calle vimos muchísima gente en las
calles todos con mascarilla algunos
guardando la distancia social otros no
una vuelta del tráfico a la normalidad
mucho tráfico en santiago como suele ser
habitual nuevos niveles de contaminación
parecidos a los que se registraban antes
de la pandemia que contamos que con la
pandemia de la contaminación al
reducirse la movilidad también bajó en
la ciudad y por primera vez en el centro
de santiago se veía también a personas
tomando una cerveza un viernes por la
tarde en una terraza en los restaurantes
en santiago la sensación en la región
metropolitana es devuelta a la norma
prácticamente total patricia alguien
chile el gobierno nacional del
presidente sebastián piñera presentó un
plan para volver a las clases
presenciales pero el plan parece que no
está funcionando muy bien qué fue lo que
pasó
así es el gobierno lleva impulsando
durante mucho tiempo la vuelta a las
clases esto viene desde hace semanas y
por finalmente esta semana se lanzó un
plan piloto en pirque una comuna a las
afueras de santiago en cinco colegios el
resultado fue un fracaso absoluto en
muchos lugares había más prensa que
alumnos en un colegio llegó una alumna y
al ver toda la prensa salió corriendo
asustado y en el colegio que más alumnos
registros fueron un total de 20 personas
sin embargo el ministro de educación
raúl figueroa hizo un balance positivo
porque el gobierno está impulsando
fuertemente la vuelta a las aulas para
que las mamás que han sido uno de los
sectores más afectados por el desempleo
durante la pandemia las mujeres puedan
volver a retomar su actividad económica
también llama mucho la atención patricia
la situación que se está presentando en
las regiones del sur la región de
magallanes aysén los lagos los ríos y de
la araucanía están presentando todavía
muchos casos de contagio para el tamaño
de la población que hay allí qué es lo
que está pasando allí en el sur del país
así el santiago en el norte se vive una
realidad del confinamiento similar a la
de otros países de américa latina y en
el sur vivimos un segundo brote de
segunda una segunda ola de la pandemia
al mismo nivel que en europa hay que
recordar que en chile el primer lugar
donde se vivió una alza de casos de
comida muy importante en abril fue
precisamente en la región de magallanes
en la puerta a la patagonia y la puerta
a la antártica y si en ese momento en
abril se registraban 50 casos al día hoy
estamos en 282 las cifras son realmente
alarmantes la tasa de positividad es del
33% frente al 65 4% a nivel nacional y
esto se debe según muchos expertos
epidemiólogos no a una suspensión de las
medidas no sean o no una puesta en pausa
de las medidas de seguridad sino una
suspensión de las mismas que habría
llevado a éstos a esta nueva ola de
contagio es muy fuerte también para
muchos la descoordinación entre los
distintos niveles de autoridad
es locales regionales nacionales habría
llevado a estas cifras que son
significativas en este momento en el
último mes 40 pacientes de esa región
que tiene muy poca población fueron
trasladados a la región metropolitana
para ser tratados por coronavirus
mientras que en abril habían sido un
total de 15 así que preocupa mucho lo
que ocurre en magallanes como un indicio
de lo que puede suceder en el resto del
país en las próximas semanas además que
insisto en el tema del clima patricia en
estas regiones todavía está haciendo
frío se han presentado nevadas en el
extremo sur del país entonces el
panorama allí es muy distinto a lo que
se registra en santiago y en el norte
grande de chile muchas gracias patricia
por este reporte desde la ciudad de
santiago y en perú después de siete
meses de restricciones el mes de octubre
comenzó con el optimismo para todos los
peruanos por ser el inicio también de la
última fase de la reapertura que le va a
permitir a este país recuperar los
puestos de trabajo y esa estrepitosa
caída de la economía peruana que ha
dejado la pandemia de cobre 19 que
todavía siguen combatiendo a dicen
francisco zacarías quien está en la
ciudad de lima la capital peruana o la
francisco en casi 200 días en estado de
emergencia allí en perú y ya entraron
tal parece en la recta final para la
reapertura completa de la economía cómo
está avanzando este proceso
buenas noches santiago le cuento que
esta reactivación la cuarta fase es
parcial en el sector comercio se ha
incrementado el aforo en las tiendas del
40 al 50 por ciento y en el caso de los
restaurantes del 50 al 60 por ciento no
están permitidos la apertura de bares
discotecas ni cines por otro lado es
autorizado que los museos y los lugares
arqueológicos comiencen a operar a
partir del 15 de octubre en el sector
transporte se ha habilitado el
funcionamiento de los ferrocarriles y
también se ha permitido que los vuelos
internacionales comiencen a operar a
partir del próximo lunes
precisamente perú va a abrir sus cielos
a siete países ellos son colombia
ecuador panamá paraguay uruguay bolivia
y chile pero las actividades son
limitadas en el sector turismo solo se
ha permitido que las agencias de viaje
comiencen a operar y que se realicen
traslados a algunos lugares y hace falta
condiciones que garanticen un acceso
seguro al lugar
turísticos como es el caso de machu
picchu donde sus autoridades han
señalado que los protocolos sanitarios
no están completos al 100% inclusive
ellos están pidiendo la dotación de
ambulancias y balones de oxígeno en la
eventualidad de un cuadro de contagios
es así que esta situación y como ellos
están diciendo que hace faltan
protocolos sanitarios está ralentizando
que la ciudadela inca todavía no
comience a recibir turistas ni los
visitantes habituales francisco
estábamos hablando de la calidad que ha
tenido la economía peruana el producto
interno bruto de perú ha sido de los que
más se ha contraído en la región de
américa latina como empieza entonces
esta cuarta etapa este proceso para
reconstruir la economía de ese país
si justamente las autoridades tienen sus
expectativas de que esta cuarta fase
dinamiza aún más la economía
se espera que en esta cuarta etapa
permita que haya un lo que es recuperar
el desempleo justamente más de 6
millones de peruanos perdieron sus
puestos de trabajo por el largo
confinamiento otro factor es recuperar
el producto bruto interno como usted lo
señalaba las autoridades peruanas
dijeron que el producto bruto interno y
va a caer 12% este año pero algunos
expertos han afirmado que esto podría
llegar inclusive hasta el 15 por ciento
otro desafío va a ser recuperar o mejor
dicho reforzar la lucha contra la
pobreza tan solo el banco central de
reserva de este país ha anunciado que un
27 por ciento de peruanos podrían quedar
en situación de pobreza esto traducido
por algunos expertos locales es que al
final de año el país podría tener más de
8 millones de peruanos en situación de
pobreza pero el desafío más importante
señalan algunos analistas es que va a
ser que esta cuarta etapa no pueda
convertirse en un probable foco de
contagio del nuevo coronavirus vamos a
ver si todos los peruanos las empresas
los trabajadores y la comunidad pueden
cumplir los protocolos preventivos que
se están previendo desde el sector salud
el gran desafío que tiene perú por
delante no solamente pero la mayoría de
los países del mundo tienen estas mismas
esta misma situación hablemos de las
cifras para el cierre de esta semana
francisco ya llegan a 800 mil o un poco
más de 800 mil casos confirmados más de
32.000 fallecidos que es una cifra
lamentable pero la tasa de contagio
parece que está empezando a retroceder
ha tenido una caída cercana al 13 por
ciento según indican algunos medios
peruanos que dicen allí
y justamente las últimas estadísticas
del ministerio de salud señalan que del
30 de septiembre al 1 de octubre están
registrado tres mil 468 casos y 72
fallecidos las autoridades sanitarias
señalan que en septiembre existe un
descenso en el registro semanal en
comparación al mes de agosto pero
algunos expertos afirman que este
descenso no es definitivo y también
sostienen que ha habido un descenso en
las pruebas de descarte de el
coronavirus esto podría ser entendido
también como que se está reduciendo la
pandemia la propagación de contagios
pero previamente a esta situación las
autoridades mejor dicho los voceros del
sector salud advirtieron que
en las próximas semanas pedro podría
presentarse en una segunda ola de
contagios del cobi 19 ante esta
situación la defensoría del pueblo le
exigido al gobierno peruano que
implemente un plan de contingencia y que
éste sea conocido por toda la población
francisco muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde la ciudad de lima
la economía argentina ya estaba en una
situación muy crítica cuando comenzó la
pandemia no ha ayudado que este país se
tenga una de las cuarentenas más largas
del mundo y que esto se ha afectado por
supuesto los puestos de trabajo el
comercio y los ingresos de los
argentinos esto ha llevado a un aumento
en los índices de pobreza que ya llegan
al 40% veamos
con una economía en recesión desde hace
dos años la pandemia llegó a argentina
como otro golpe más con una cuarentena
que se decretó en marzo y ha empezado a
flexibilizarse desde mayo la pobreza se
muestra como un indicador al alza en
medio de este panorama según el
instituto nacional de estadística de
pobreza alcanzó en el primer semestre
del año el 49 por ciento de la población
un repunte de más de 5 puntos sobre el
final de año pero según unas
estimaciones anticipadas de la
universidad católica de argentina hasta
junio la pobreza era de entre el 46% y
el 47 por ciento de shock han sido en la
estructura productiva la declinación de
empleo en el cuenta propia incluso
informal bueno entonces mayor pobreza
general todos somos un poco más pobres
ya lo veremos aquí el año pasado
ahora más
durante la cuarentena en argentina se
han destruido tres millones y medio de
puestos de trabajo la mayoría informales
como el de guillermo 15 gana la vida
como vendedor ambulante en eventos
deportivos sobreviví por la familia que
me apoyaba pero era apoyaba también
económicamente porque no tenía ninguna
posibilidad de hacer nada no hay no
habían en ningún evento como pasaría a
vender mi trabajo como para hacer el
gobierno ha dado subsidios de unos 125
dólares mensuales a 9 millones de
personas y también promueve los
comedores populares de acuerdo con las
cifras oficiales más de la mitad de los
niños son pobres y en el segundo
trimestre del año la caída del producto
interior bruto fue de un 19,1 por ciento
es el peor dato de este tipo desde que
se realiza el registro incluso superando
el del primer trimestre del 2002 que fue
del 16 3% en medio de la crisis del
corralito
vamos ahora a la región de américa
central y del caribe comenzamos en
guatemala y el gobierno puso en marcha
unas nuevas medidas aquí esta semana le
permiten la reapertura de los teatros
los cines bares pero con limitaciones el
avance de la reapertura animó a
migrantes hondureños a retomar sus
caravanas en un intento por llegar a
estados unidos- muchos han cruzado la
frontera de manera ilegal hacia
guatemala en cuba' fue levantada la
medida de toque de queda que fue
impuesta en la capital en la ciudad de
la habana que fue impuesta el pasado
primero de septiembre aún así la ciudad
seguirá con un acceso restringido desde
y hacia las provincias cubanas no muy
lejos de allí en bahamas alcanzaron los
4 mil 200 casos la mayoría están
concentrados en la isla gran bahama
ábaco y nueva providencia el gobierno ha
sido fuertemente criticado por la
precipitada apertura del archipiélago el
primero de julio que habría sido el
origen de este rebrote que están
viviendo ahora un poco más al sur en
trinidad y tobago así superaron los 4
mil 600 casos y contabilizaron dos
muertes en un período de 24 horas
lo que puso en alerta a las autoridades
este archipiélago tiene una leve
apertura social pero sus fronteras
siguen cerradas para los extranjeros en
nuestra sección en redes veamos otras
noticias que también fueron destacadas a
lo largo de esta semana llegó a
venezuela el primer lote de la vacuna
sputnik ve de fabricación rusa venezuela
se convierte así en el primer país de
occidente en recibir el lote de esta
vacuna para ensayos de la fase 3 dos mil
personas en la ciudad de caracas están
incluidas para este ensayo clínico y el
ex primer ministro de portugal y ex
presidente de la comisión europea jose
manuel durao barroso fue nombrado
presidente de la alianza global para las
vacunas un cargo que no tiene
remuneración económica y que jugará un
papel clave en la distribución de las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 una vez sean
desarrolladas
es todo por el momento en este resumen
de kobe 19 la semana en américa nos
volvemos a encontrar la próxima semana
siga con la programación de france 24
[Música]